and talking about dark waters one of the
good things but I guess for you talking
about this film is going in
we know DuPont did it you can't spoil
this plot for us because your experience
on Avengers as you've just you've had a
litany of plots port excuse me I'm the
best
you're largely better than Tom Hollands
but that is what I taught Tom tell us
about the was it the premiere of Thor
oka what are you they can't fart no they
tried
if you don't know this story this is
what happened they asked me to do social
media backstage and at that time it was
like Facebook Live had just hit the apps
I was back there doing my face time
Facebook liveing and I thought I hit the
off button but I didn't realize it had
two different lost buttons and I went on
everyone else ran to my seat they
started the movie I put my my phone in
my pocket and I'm sitting there watching
it and I'm like five minutes in and my
phone is blowing up and everyone and
their mother was texting me from all
over the world to tell me that my phone
was on and that was live broadcasting
the movie of course I'm a gentleman so I
don't check my phone
so finally they sent the lady down and
she like what what and she's like yeah
phone your phone is on I was like no
it's not it's a it's in my pocket just
like it's on it's on I pulled it out at
night
uh-huh I get a call from Kevin Feige oh
the big boss the boss he's like what are
you doing man I said Kevin it was an
accident I swear to god they told me to
use the Facebook live I don't know how
to use it it's like you can't do this
stuff I was like no no you're right sir
and the next day I showed up to do press
and I'm I'm hurting I I can't look
anyone in the eyes and I walk over to
him to say sorry and he grabs me in a
bear hug and he's like that was genius
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
you